did you think computing will eat
everything in this in some certain sense
or almost like disappear because it's
part of everything oh it's so funny you
say that so i want to say it's going to
metastasize
but there's kind of two ways that fields
destroy themselves one is
they become super narrow and i think we
can think of
fields that might be that way they
become pure
and we have that instinct we have that
impulse i'm sure you can think of
several people who want
computer science to be this pure thing
the other way is you
become everywhere and you become
everything and nothing and so everyone
says
you know i'm going to teach fortran for
engineers or whatever i'm going to
do this and then you lose the thing that
makes it worth studying
in and of itself the thing about
computing and this is not unique to
computing
though at this point in time it is
distinctive about computing where we
happen to be in 2020
is we are both a thriving major in fact
the thriving major
almost every place and
we're a service unit because people need
to know
the things we need to know and our job
much as the mathematician's job is to
help
you know this person over here to think
like a mathematician much of the way the
point isn't the point of you taking
chemistry as a freshman
is not to learn chemistry it's to learn
to think like a scientist right our job
is to help them to think
think like a computationalist then we
have to take both of those things very
seriously and i'm not sure that as a
field we have historically
certainly taken the second thing that
our job is to help them to think a
certain way
people aren't going to be i mean i don't
think we've taken that that very
seriously at all
i don't know if you know who dan carlin
is he has this podcast called hardcore
history yes i've
just did an amazing um four-hour
conversation with him mostly about
hitler
but i i i bring him up because he
talks about this idea that it's possible
that history as a field
will become like currently most people
study history a little bit we kind of
are aware of it we have a conversation
about it
different parts of it i mean there's a
lot of criticism to say that some parts
of history being ignored blah blah blah
so on but most people are able to to uh
have a curiosity and able to learn it
the his thought is it's possible given
the way social media works the the
current way we communicate that history
becomes a niche field
where literally most people just ignore
because everything is happening so fast
that the history starts losing its
meaning and then
it starts being a thing that only
you know it's like the theoretical
computer science part of computer
science
it becomes a niche thing that only like
the rare holders of the
the world wars and the you know uh all
the history the founding of the united
states all those kinds of things the
civil wars
and it's a kind of profound thing to
think about
how these how we can lose track
how we can lose these fields when
they're best
like in the case of history it's best
for that to be a pervasive thing that
everybody
learns and thinks about and so on and i
would say computing is
quite obviously similar to history
in the sense that it seems like it
should be uh
a part of everybody's life to some
degree and especially like as we move
into the
later parts of the 21st century and
it's not obvious that that's the way
it'll go it might be in the hands of the
few
still like it depending if it's machine
learning
you know it's on it's unclear that it'll
computing will win out
it's currently very successful but it's
not i i would say
that's something i mean you're at the
leadership level of this
you're defining the future so it's in
your hands
no pressure but like it feels like
there's multiple ways this can go
and there's this kind of conversation of
everybody uh should learn to code
right the changing nature of jobs and so
on
do you have a sense of
what your role in uh
education of computing is here like
what's the hopeful path forward
there's a lot there i i will i will say
that well first off it would be an
absolute shame
if no one studied history uh on the
other hand as t approaches infinity the
amount of history
is presumably also growing at least
linearly and so
uh it's you you have to forget more and
more
of history but history needs to always
be there i mean i can imagine a world
where
you know if you think of your brains as
being you know outside of your head
that you can kind of learn the history
you need to know when you need to know
it
that seems fanciful but it's a it's a
kind of way of you know
is there a sufficient statistic of
history no and there's certainly
but there may be for the particular
thing you have to care about but you
know those who do not
remember our objective camera discussion
right yeah it's
right and you know we've already lost
lots of history and of course you have
your own history that
some of which will be are it's even lost
to you right you don't even remember
whatever it was you were doing 17 years
ago all the ex-girlfriends
yeah they're gone exactly so
you know history is being lost anyway
but the big lessons of history shouldn't
be
and i think you know to take it to the
question of computing and sort of
education the point is you have to get
across those lessons you have to get
across the way of thinking
um and you have to be able to go back
and you know you don't want to lose the
data even if you know you don't
necessarily have the information at your
fingertips with computing i think it's
somewhat different everyone doesn't have
to learn how to
code but everyone needs to learn how to
think in the way that you can be
precise and i mean precise in the sense
of repeatable not just
you know in the sense of not resolution
in the sense of get the right number of
bits
um in saying what it is you want the
machine to do and being able to describe
a problem
in such a way that it is executable
which we are not human beings are not
very good at that
in fact i think we spend much of our
time talking back and forth just to kind
of vaguely understand
what the other person means and hope we
get it good enough that we can we can
act accordingly
you can't do that with machines at least
not yet and so
you know having to think that precisely
about things is quite important and
that's somewhat different from
coding coding is a crude
means to an end on the other hand the
idea of coding
what that means that it's a programming
language and it has these sort of
things that you fiddle with in these
ways that you express that is an
incredibly important point in fact i
would argue that
one of the big holes in machine learning
right now in ai is that
we forget that we are basically doing
software engineering we forget that we
are doing
um we are using programming like we're
using languages to express what we're
doing like it's just so all caught up in
the deep network or we get all caught up
in whatever that we forget that
you know we're making decisions
based upon a set of parameters that we
made up and if we did slightly different
parameters we'd have completely
different
different outcomes and so the lesson of
computing computer science education
is to be able to think like that and to
be aware of it when you're doing it
basically it's a
you know then today it's a way of
surfacing your assumptions
i mean we call them parameters or you
know we we call them
if-then statements or whatever but
you're forced to surface those
those assumptions that's the key the key
thing that you should get out of a
computing education that and that the
models the languages and the machines
are equivalent but
it actually follows from that that you
have to be explicit about
about what it is you're trying to do
because the model you're building is
something you will one day
run so you better get it right or at
least understand it and be able to
express
roughly what what you want to express so
i think it is key
that we figure out how to
educate everyone to think that way
because at the end it would not only
make them better at whatever it is that
they
are doing and i emphasize doing
it'll also make them better citizens
it'll help them to understand what
others are doing to them so that they
can
react accordingly because you're not
going to solve the problem of social
media
insofar as you think of social media as
a problem
by just making slightly better code
right it only works if people
react to it appropriately and know
what's happening
and therefore take control over what
they're doing
i mean that's that's my take on
you